my son I have a little boy little baby I
find him very exciting he's teething now
it's all I you know it it's all very
boring and predictable but uh you know
it's pretty exciting for me I'm not I
can't say I'm excited by any particular
new TV show or books or or any political
development i'm fascinated by what's
going on out there but um but but
nothing nothing's exciting me quite like
having a little boy so I I am definitely
a mammal
it's still strictly education and I one
of the reasons i would also write for
young audiences I don't think there's
anything better a child can do than read
there's if we can get our children to
read you know were set and I probably
think that because I'm a reader but I do
think that's you know necessary for a
intelligent child and for a flourishing
democracy again you know I ears ago when
I was last interviewed by big think
nothing has changed in our education
system it's to this I don't remember
what we talked about but it's the same
problem that we talked about then
everyone talks about fixing our schools
and nobody does anything there's
actually an exciting charter school I
really don't know much about it out and
one of the borough's here where they are
paying every teacher a hundred thousand
dollars which was actually an idea I had
several years ago and I'm very curious
to hear how that goes over because I
think the number one thing we can do was
put yeah look Oliver in the book
probably the main reasoning age school
besides the fact that he's smarter than
everybody is he has no respect for his
teachers you know some of these teachers
are petty tyrant most teachers are great
people but anyone who's been to school
which is all of us knows you get your
petty tyrants you get your dim bulbs you
get your narcissus I think you know if I
just know too many new too many really
smart interesting people in college who
would have loved to gone into teaching
because they love going to school if
they thought they could have supported
their families doing
you